[Applause]
Peggy
[Applause]
thank you the first Sanjay I mean it
honestly it feels like I was just
talking to you for the first time when
you became the doctor yeah and this many
years have passed and you can see here
from the reaction you can see what these
people in the audience are feeling that
they love you they love you as the
doctor what is your what is this last
few years been like for you fantastic
it's amazing but yeah time ran away with
my I don't know how we got here so
quickly
yeah terrifying but it's just been
fabulous to work with all of these guys
to work with such talent and also to to
meet you people to realize that the show
is so popular and so beloved all around
the world is it's remarkable to find
yourself at the center of that so thank
you for all of your affectionate support
it was really at the top let's talk a
little about the Christmas episode
obviously it was amazing that you were
able even put that together because I
know you literally just wrapped yeah so
what can you say about the Christmas
episode is there any information that
you have and and what can people look
forward to well I kind of think if you
probably figured out what we're doing
here in part it's the 12th doctor right
refusing to regenerate because he wants
to stay Scottish and as he staggers out
the TARDIS through the snow appears the
first doctor also refusing to regenerate
and it's the two of them is the 12th
doctor saying to number one listen you
have to wear all this stuff won't happen
and the first doctor say more what about
you they go off on a crazy adventure
with Mark Gatiss
and and bill pot and this us
and decides whether or not they're going
to carry on which of course they are
right and David Bradley is amazing cat
he was in adventure in space in time yes
exactly yes so but the idea that you
would get the guy who played William
Hartnell to then play the first doctor
as a whip how long ago did you start
crafting that New York comic-con this
moment must be on video because somebody
asked about what the choice of doctors
and day of the doctor and I said well
obviously the doctor you'd want to come
and meet the modern doctor is William
Hartnell but he will return my calls
right and I'm here said well we could
just get David Bradley so I presume one
video I'm going on yeah and we did and I
have to say his recreation of William
Hartnell is absolutely extraordinary
there are moments if you if you put it
in black and white you could fool people
I gives it such twinkle such grace and
because of the obvious background
knowledge or his considerable knowledge
from Mark's wonderful movie um he he
just captures what the first doctor was
really like not the crotchety old man of
legend but a much twinkly a funnier more
engaging man than that
right well I think people are very
excited to see you return I'm very
excited to to be honest ah thank you
Epping did you feel it right away when
you when you first came into the show
did you understand the fandom and did
you feel the the swell that was
happening well I think when um when I
was announced it was it was pretty epic
you know that the response was was large
but by no means is it compared to the
amount of people that are sitting in
front of me at the moment this is
incredible yeah it's amazing
um so no I think the answer the short
answer is I I don't think I was prepared
for how how powerful the dr. Hugh fandom
is I think it's such an incredible thing
and it's such a it's such a gift to be
able to be part of this sort a family
with kids thanks for having me and are
you you you may have already confirmed
or denied this in the press but you are
you
you're not coming back after the
Christmas special you are oh that's it
yeah Christmas special last chance to
see bill but I mean hey it's not - who
so never say never so just a little bit
can you talk a little bit about who bill
was to you and did what did you learn
about her throughout the process was she
different by the end by the time you
came out the other end of it in your
mind yeah I mean she was a Cyberman not
quite I mean she doesn't ever get
rescued in a beautifully romantic which
I by the way the girl with the star I
haven't figured out is that still the
girl or is it the pilot like where's
there traces of her in there still boy
still it's still high yes okay she's
retained her personality but she's
transformed as people sometimes do an
all-powerful alien entity who can rescue
you romantically actually and you're out
of darkest need and don't we all need
that
absolutely yeah someone with a star eye
rising out of a puddle to say I will
take you and then go off so what did you
what what was special to you about Bill
and what are you going to miss the most
um I think what was really special to me
about bill was that she was so she's so
real I think she said she feels very
there's so many different elements to
her you know there's says she's very
quick-witted and she's very inquisitive
but someone putted quite well today
during one of our roundtable interviews
notice little sort of like childlike
curiosity to her as well which which i
think is great because i mean who wants
to grow up um and i think that's one of
the one of the things that I really like
about her you know she's there's a lot
of she's very strong-minded and she she
really believes in what she does and she
I think she does everything quite
deliberately but then you know
accidentally she'll sort of wander off
and get nearly dragged into a puddle and
I emailed Matt Lucas last week just to
say that I think nardole is a triumph I
loved him I loved him a lot
it's just thank you we it's nice to be
here earth is one of my favorite planets
sorry I mean for you
you know I assume that you were probably
I've always been a huge Doctor Who fan
yeah I mean growing up I was a fan and
then and then when I was about thirteen
they stopped making it for about a
million years which was a bit
inconvenient but yeah it was it's a
pinch yourself moment when you get asked
to be in the show so every single day I
I walked on set I felt very very lucky
to be there who was who was he in the
beginning and where did he come out at
the end what was what do you think his
narrative arc was well I think the
Christmas specials have a slightly
different identity to the regular series
in that they're a bit lighter and bolder
because people in Britain on Christmas
Day eat turkey and there's an enzyme in
Turkey that makes you fall asleep so the
Christmas special has to keep you awake
and so na Dahl was very broad I think at
the beginning and I just thought excuse
me I just thought oh I'm just doing a
cameo in Doctor Who what a treat but
across the series I realized from a
performance point of view I had to try
and find a bit more nuance and texture
in there but also there was more time
and space to develop that in terms of
the writing as well so yeah it was it
was good to try and and develop
different sides of the character yeah
that's my answer
Oh wonderful what I love the answer it
was I just want to say to Michelle I
think Missy is such a stunning parable
and
your your portrayal of her it's so
gorgeous
and layered and because I think you know
with a character like the character like
the master Missy you you there could be
a you know oh this is an evil character
but she's not she really seems like she
wants to do good she's really struggling
against her own nature did you feel that
with her absolutely it's that tug of war
you know should I do something good I
shall I do something bad
obviously I'll do something bad as if
the pool to darkness is too strong and
but what was fun was the sort of you
know toy with the idea of being good and
and also I think um to get away from
that two-dimensional character that she
could have been a kid of being you know
black and white and is to sort of sit in
that area and that can agree area of
emotionality where it is with
interesting to possibly try on good for
a minute and see how that feels and it
was really hard actually when you're
looking into a face like Peter Capaldi's
with those great big blue watery gray
eyes and and and just want to kind of
you know be his friend and then
obviously not
was with it was difficult a chunky
presented me with a challenge he really
did because it's hard to act with this
man and not want to be your best self
but it but it's it's also that arc of
friendship yeah and these beings we've
been around for so long and and and that
relationships are naturally complex and
that's that this is the history there
that you know there was a great
friendship once and it is a little bit
like you know that friend that you all
had that you were very close with and
then one day that friendship just starts
to crack and break and you have a little
bit of distance and time and then you
meet them again a hundred years later
and you remember why you deleted them
from your phone in the first place is
that type of dynamic love/hate and also
really fun to see John Simm come back to
and well be able to I
I had to say if I'm going to love myself
it was very nice to get a chance to love
Jones him yeah but Missy shuts him down
like he goes for us and I guess she
crushed him like a bug ya know some it
was all very wrong Steven there was
something very wrong about all of that
indeed but yes it was an acting
challenge that I hoped I was you wanted
to do with a beard though didn't I did
it with a beard yeah how do you how do
you think she is how do you think she's
handling dealing because you know
everyone would love the opportunity to
look at their younger self and say stop
being an idiot
because he's obviously very singularly
focused and she's much more grown-up and
complicated by this point so what is it
that you think she is really wanting to
convey to him in the last moments where
they essentially two have each other in
the back and it's interesting that she
get any sort of they kill each other
somebody suggested it might have been
suicide there's a little dark but I
think it's just that you know you've
just got to stay open to whatever it's
put in front of you and stay flexible
and that would be ed and so she was just
basically telling John scented to do
some yoga mark what about you for the
season what is it what does this season
meant to you what does this been like so
far and kind of knowing that it's you
know ramping down and things are about
to change well it's a strange moment you
know it's the end of several eras and
you it has that kind of melancholy to it
but it's also it's been a fantastic
season I think it was a joy to do my ice
warriors episode and be part of this of
this great new feel for it all I think
it's some Christmas is a terrific
episode I'm very privileged to be in and
to be there for for Peter's exit with
Peter and David and we've had a great
time doing it I think it's a lovely it's
a lovely way out editor it's very
Christmas the episode without being sort
of on the nose Christmasy it's sort of
sad you know it's got all those things
that Christmas brings up the new it's a
lovely exit and we've had a great time
doing it I want to kind of spend the
rest of the panel we're going to show
you a clip we're going to take a look
back at the last few seasons with Peter
we're going to have some time for
audience questions I also want to say
that as you exit I am very excited to
see Jodie Whittaker come in as 13 I
think she's going to be an excellent
choice but you know at the same time I'm
also very sad to see you go and this is
the thing that the show has done with us
since the beginning which is someone new
comes in there's about five minutes
where you're like I don't know about
this and then after two episodes you're
like please don't go anywhere ever you
know that was the same speech he made
the last time I was here it's a hundred
percent true not any less true you're
absolutely right because that's what the
show does every single time and you can
see it pearl in nardole like everyone is
freaking out that you know and you saw
the oh don't go anywhere you know I mean
this show is about attachment and having
to rip that away and get reattached the
entire time which spiritually is what it
must feel like to be the doctor I would
imagine
well it's astonishing because I just
wanted to say that some I think Jody is
going to be amazing I spoke to her the
other day and she's so full of
excitement and so full of passion about
the show she really loves the show and
she's a brilliant actress so it's really
thrilling to know that it's in the hands
of somebody who who cares for it so
deeply and it's going to do really
really exciting things with it which is
a great choice as far as I'm concerned
yes I agree and
I don't know I feel I just feel I don't
know why they it's a bit tokenistic to
cast a human as the doctor no we're
making progress you know we're making
progress or make a bit I could I just
say something as well I just wanted
because I say I'm sure a lot of people
miss remar feeling exactly as I do there
is um I so many press articles about a
backlash among Doctor Who fandom against
the casting of a female doctor
there has been no backlash at all but
the story of the moment is that is that
the notionally conservative doctor who
found them is utterly embraced that
change completely
80% approval on social media not that I
check these things obsessively and yet
so many people wanting to pretend
there's a problem there isn't in fact it
strikes me the Doctor Who fans are more
excited about the idea of a brilliant
actress playing the part then the fact
she's a woman it's been incredibly
progressive and enlightened and that's
what's really happened I wish every
single journalist who is writing the
alternative would shut the hell up it's
not true oh yeah
also if you call yourself a fan of
Doctor Who you buy innately couldn't be
upset by that because high marks can
regenerate in anything goes you're an
[ __ ]
[Applause]
but you you're not a real fan of the
show if you don't accept this it is 100%
with it you mean like everything about
it so but I really want to spend the
last bit of time talking about you and
being able to send you off here at
comic-con it's very special that you all
were here we put together just a few
minute clip from the last few years of
you as the doctor so let's roll that and
then we'll come back and then we'll go
to audience questions
[Applause]
I never had a standing ovation lifetime
you can do whatever you want anything
you wanted we find the great show this
guy created this guy this this show this
show I mean every shot you saw there I
came through this gentleman's mind knew
his eye through his sensibility through
his generosity you know he put together
an incredible team he's incredibly
gifted artist but the message of
kindness comes from his heart and also
the creation of a female doctor comes
really from the creation of a female
master played so beautifully by Michelle
who has delivered a multi-layered
hilarious sinister and fabulous
performance for which I'm deeply
grateful so Jody the idea of a Time Lord
being both male and female came from
Steve Carroll has been an absolutely
magnificent new contribution to the show
she steps into this this this juggernaut
that we have
and brought us a real living character
in bill Potts
who had two feet on the ground and her
heart and the star which is where we all
want to be right matt has come along and
delivered a fabulous creation a whole
brand-new thing an alien being who is a
sidekick who's a little bit scary a
little bit funny and a huge contribution
to the show and has come into it with a
generosity of spirit and kindness
because this is a man who is immensely
famous immensely talented and he stepped
up to the plate in our show with
humility and grace and made season 10
one of the most special seasons ever
mark what can I say about mark is a
great great friend a great lover and
supporter of Doctor Who and all that
sounds a bit odd that doctor who needs
lovers and supporters but the show
hasn't always enjoyed the success that
it enjoys at the moment it's not always
been the most popular show to to hang
your your coat on mark has always been
there for the show he's written some of
the most fabulous episodes and I'm so
thrilled that he's finally been able to
appear in the show and I was able to act
with him so thank you very much
Oh God I just did a big screech there I
didn't really like no I don't know what
thank you for this uh San Diego our
water award and you're sensational - oh
stop it come on
Yolo Thanks a command thank you I burned
the battery out forfeited um when you
first started was this experience
anything like you had predicted I know
that you were a fan of the show you know
we've talked about that many times
before but when you were describing the
12th doctor as a fan how would you
describe him as a fan yeah as a fan I
love him he's my favorite doc he's
certainly the most handsome in my eyes
and he's got the biggest hair yes his
hair had the biggest rock doesn't it
really too small and got bigger and
bigger and bigger
um I think he's an alien
that's what what my sort of ambition
with him was to to make him not a human
being but whatever strange and
mysterious creature the doctor is I
don't know what kind of creature he is
he he has a human sensibility above him
and we perceive him as a human but I
don't believe that's what he is I think
he's stranger and darker and cleverer so
I wanted to invest him with a sense of
that and also fun and clownish nests and
silliness and wittiness and all the rest
of it Stephen supplies all that thanks
man
so when you were a child and you were
watching Doctor Who and you probably
thought oh it'd be really amazing to be
the doctor wow what an amazing
opportunity what was something that you
discovered having done this for the last
years or like all I never knew it would
be like this like what's one thing
what's a piece of advice that you would
give practical advice for playing the
doctor to anyone who might do so gentle
enough sleep
because they're going to be up early
everyday and be there all the time and
then learn all your lines sent them I
never I never grew up thinking what we
like to play the doctor I just thought
the doctor was the most an amazing
character that I could see and so I
didn't despite the publicity departments
of efforts to make everyone believe this
and they were successful I didn't spend
my whole life grieving about the fact
that I wasn't playing Doctor Who I was
just getting on with my life as an actor
but but I loved it the show and the
character deeply so it was a great
thrill and surprised to find myself in
it and you even just said this is
something I wanted a Steven about
there's a really nice nugget
specifically I feel like aimed at the
fans in season 10 where they actually
have the debate of is he the doctor or
is he called Doctor Who and a lot of
people if they go who's gonna play
doctor we will go it's a doctor that's
not a name but other people don't agree
with that assessment so do you have a
final word on this either way or do you
think III defer to mr. jipner
obviously um but if you take continuity
seriously and be honest you all do there
isn't any doubt about this I'm sorry it
was established in the war machines that
his name is Doctor Who all right there
is he was called doctor majority doctor
and when when when people call out to
you in the street they say I'll say
hello the doctor they say Doctor Who he
doesn't often call himself Doctor Who
because he's a bloody stupid name but he
that must be a nice Raines himself dr. W
the third doctor had a car with who on
the license plate he is not a master of
subtlety he thought in order to be
mysterious I'll call myself Doctor Who
however if you prefer to believe that
he's really it that he calls himself the
doctor and that's just the name of the
show that's also equally true because
what would Doctor Who continuity be
without blatant and unresolvable
contradiction
[Applause]
but nobody's nobody's first name is
actually dr. dr. who no yeah Vinnie no
here's the doctor maybe his first name
we just don't know maybe it's illa real
Michael hi Michael who it's doctor all
right let's take some audience questions
because I want to have a little extra
time because I know that this is very
important for all of you so what is your
name in question I am I'm Jonah I'm
sorry I was very taken with with this
whole panel actually yeah and um first I
wanna thank you Peter and Steven for
just donating so much of your time and
energy to this show of making some
unforgettable episodes and some
unforgettable years and oh and I'm what
I was wondering is um every doctor kind
of has that iconic moment that when you
think of that doc do you think at that
moment so Peter what do you think is
your iconic moment by the way you don't
need to be nervous that was an amazing
question that was an amazing question
that I think huh I think my iconic
moment was decided for me which is the
best iconic moments always are and it
was this one
which is where my eyes appeared my
eyebrows appeared in the the 50th
anniversary special and that sort of I
guess sort of said what my doctor was
going to be and you know a middle aged
Scotsman with hairy eyebrows which there
are many thank you so much
[Laughter]
my question is what is all of your
favorite doctors and companions favorite
favorite doctors and companions well I
can now reveal it because I'm quit I'm
leaving
so it's no longer contentious my
favorite doctor unequivocally is Doctor
Who that's the best answer other doctors
hang around hospitals and cure colds
they're just rubbish have you seen none
no alien robots no time machines they
are not worthy of the name doctor it's
that Doctor Who it's awesome
investigate any improvised moment well
Peter and pearl are both looking at me
and I kept putting things in and I'm
sorry about that there's a few I I said
some of my best friends of bluish that
was one of mine there's there a few
there are few yeah well we all yeah I
mean I mean yeah we probably all but we
all put stuff in didn't we but I was not
as much I improvised too much B to be
honest yeah and then there's the edit
that's not fair actually my favorite
addition that you put in Matt wasn't
actually a funny line it was just after
the doctor had said his lemon drops line
you said oh you're very silly sometimes
yeah I loved that line I thought yeah I
thought you can be very silly sometimes
you know because I suppose it was
because people are always saying people
at that point was saying how silly
nardole was so I thought it was nice to
him Cecilia clearly the silliest man in
the show to tell off the most serious
man of her for being silly yeah well
thank you for letting me ruin the show
with a way thank you so much for a
question hey what is your name hi my
name is Jessica and I just have to tell
Peter again you are my favorite doctor
you won the game because you encompassed
all the doctors within your performance
and I love the nods you did to previous
doctors in there it really gave us a
peek into his brain
so my question though just they're not
laughing at you the guy behind you who
looks like he sells drug spells to first
years at Hogwarts is continuing to plot
something thank you so I just want to
let you know thank you I didn't want you
to feel that it was the hair yeah
your hair is awesome thank you TARDIS
blue so my question is actually for
Steven and mark
now that you've worked with Peter as a
doctor would you be interested in having
him be a professor with the last name
Van Helsing what sorry Oh van Helsing
yeah are you trying to get me away yeah
here it's not okay to split them a fiver
Alaska quest we're going to work with
you again May you're not it's not over
you didn't know my sister was American
I'm curious for you pearl what are you
what are you going to miss the most of
this brief journey that you've had all
of it um I don't know I feel too
attached to it still to look it as
objectively as that I think maybe after
some sleep and say sunshine I might be
able to think about it more clearly but
it's been it's been such an amazing
journey is such a it's such an
incredible show and it's so well loved
and it's it's so amazing to have been
able to work with people who I have
admired for many many years so yeah I
would say probably that I think working
with all of you guys has been so amazing
so I'll miss that let's do it again
sometime well because it you know as an
actor approaches feels like oh okay well
you know I obviously like the show but
this is a you know it's a job we got to
go to work we got to get these done like
you were saying but but when you see
that it's actually such a lifestyle for
people I mean people will be cosplaying
as bill for the rest of time now like
you will see as you are a part of the
universe now and that's indelible and I
think you know particularly now it's
nice to feel like to have a war
where we see that oh yeah okay it's not
all crap someone has our back out there
you know someone really does have our
back out there I mean that's that's form
of escapism in that form of hope is
really important right now so something
that has been really special for me is
being able to watch the showing like oh
there is a perfect world somewhere what
is your name
my name is Russ and my question is for
the cast there's a lot of great monsters
and creatures within the Doctor Who
universe and I'm wondering if you guys
have ever thought of something on your
own and tried to bring it up if anything
that you really wanted to see is just an
hourly denied or just you haven't talked
about it ever Rober gloves rubber gloves
coming alive hahaha just off the cuff
they are great jelly rubber marigold
suggested coming at you and the type of
thing I suggested um I suggested it a
monster that makes everyone gay
particularly men between the ages of 22
and 28 but they did not go for that no
think so e-verify that
what about you what about you or was
there was there a particular monster
that you want to see on the show if
there a particular month I wanted him
show I don't know maybe like a linking
kind of like a hair monster yeah I feel
like there's a lot of hair going on on
the show and was um it's big but I mean
if we if I if I stand behind you then it
looks like you I mean I did it I did it
earlier is it good this is good really
good
so you see there is a lot of hair on the
show so you know maybe you maybe some
kind of wig that just continued and
gives you an afro just just sort of off
the top of my head Hey
fine fine
I'm curious even do you feel like you
did everything you wanted to do at this
point do you feel like there is anything
left undone
oh well that's loads of Doctor Who left
undone it's still got another 400 years
to run so that that's fine I mean no I
mean I I've done what I've written 42
episodes and probably rewritten the same
number again I've done as much as I can
think of I think what got me through the
the end was knowing that there was a
finish line
so I loved the show more than any other
thing I will ever do I know that I
absolutely know that but I also know
that comes a point where you you've kind
of done everything you can think of I
can think of it's time for somebody else
to come in and and have much better
ideas than me that's that that's the way
it works and that's and that's right and
proper it's you know it's emotional to
leave well mostly the moment I'm having
the emotion of thinking hey I've got
time off but you know what I will
the main thing I'll miss I suppose is
this I mean I literally in my life never
sit in a room of 7,000 people I'm
faintly irritating again you know that's
a unique experience what of your name ah
kameena are you a Dalek but a Dalek
who's a fan of all the doctors it turns
out I went rogue
[Laughter]
what is your what is your question rope
Dalek my question goes to all of the
cast
what was your ferris seem to record
during season ten a particular theme
that sticks out that you like Peter um
the scene where I got to do for Lucy an
Aikido oh yeah that was my most thing
because we studied that mark and I I
studied that very intently yeah make
sure that we had a very accurate Jon
Pertwee asked noise and pose and I hope
he's looking down on us and smiling
lettre got it back Michelle do you have
a particular scene the dance scene I
just loved all of our lines Lee wasn't
we're talking about our boy the blue
gang and he was he was brilliant and it
was a very it was just a fun kind of
ensemble day where we all really enjoyed
each other immensely I can I can say I
really obviously really enjoyed working
with everyone here but my pick a moment
which is in oxygen episode 5 I think it
was episode 5 where nardole runs round
the corner and says there's a rescue
ship on the way and I loved it because
never does anyone with this face get to
say a line like that inside and that's a
good reason and but I am never ever
normally entrusted with a line of
dialogue like that so it was just lovely
to go there's a rescue ship on the way
so that was my favorite moment what
about you pearl um I think my favorite
with them the scene with with you and I
on the roof Peter at the end of not the
end in episode 11 when it was absolutely
pissing down with Rose this was
literally like raining like rain like
you only get in Wales you probably not
familiar with it but it rains a lot it's
just like someone just pouring water
onto you and this hair not good so by
which I thought was really lovely is
them I thought it's really lovely
just for that all of the all of the crew
were all kind of there and we were all
sort of just clear to go in it together
and
eating wet kebabs I'm getting more and
more progressively damper filming this
really really beautiful theme that was
just really nice and quiet and honest
and yeah I really that was my favorite
act I talk really quickly about being
down a hall with John Semin Matt Lucas
please well first and Peter Capaldi's is
being held by a Cyberman and one of the
most beautiful shots where the weather
smokes just clears and we're coming back
and through into the internet seen
recently Marcus Johnson and I was not
and we deckchair so no massive hall a
big gravel hole just going which I like
a custard cream I think I'll have a
hobnob and it was all about the biscuits
really and that and I'm sorry has just
completely destroyed that moment thank
you so much for your question
hey what's your name yeah you stop that
right now
stop it okay I'm going to eat you after
how did you how to do that you should
take it by the shoulders and just do
this shake however okay she wanted to
know what was the hardest thing you did
in the show Oh what was the hardest
thing you did in the show I had to die
twice on one day
that was pretty tough and I had to keep
a straight face when that happened so
that was my hardest dinner with the
hurted I'm leaving it even for him even
for the doctor I mean even like that
jamming his hands in the snow that one
shot and he's fighting against
regeneration and saying he's fighting
against I don't want to go I don't want
to go
he even until the end is a fighter you
know it's it's it's um you know every
day is as its hardships doesn't it
obviously it doesn't get as wonderful
but every day there's something
difficult often that one of the
difficult things to do on a regular
basis is to look at the monster that's
not quite as cosmic as you had hope and
invest it with all the old horror and
terror that you had hoped after reading
when you write the script
you thought the monster with what's
going to be like but in fact all that
does is make you respect the other
doctors more because we do the show at a
time when we have a lot of more money
and a lot of technology and most of our
stuff looks amazing and all the previous
doctors have worked really with a lot of
unconvincing latex rubber and cardboard
and rice and porridge and stuff and
never for a second
have they ever shown you anything all
the utter commitment to that truth
that's great acting you know it's really
really good acting when you've got body
monster
you